drunk man responds why are you a lawyer
which the man replies no
[Music]
no matter where i go people just sit
down and read mean lawyer jokes to me
devin i'm so glad you're here listen i
got some more here check this out check
this out
[Music]
what happened when the semicolon broke
grammar laws
what happened
it was given two consecutive sentences
duh no yeah maybe okay no maybe we got
more we got more
[Music]
we've had a horrible winter this year
it was so cold
lawyers were walking around with their
hands in their own pockets okay hold on
when when you need a lawyer you are
incredibly happy to pay them what they
are asking for that's that's that's not
fair
[Music]
then listen i don't make the rules okay
how about this one i mean i don't know
why i just found these lying around
these are everywhere at this resort tell
me about it how do you sorry how do you
make a group of lawyers smile for a
photo this is important on vacation how
do you make a group of lawyers smile for
a photo ready here we go
just say
fees
a bargain at any price
[Music]
i heard you can get lawyers at ikea now
they're very affordable
but you have to
build your own case well i mean that's
not true a lawyer will definitely build
a case for you objection objection
no i just always want to do it i'm so
sorry
[Music]
sam i'm so happy to see you shut up what
is the difference between a cat and a
comma what's the difference between a
cat and a comma one has claws at the end
of its paws and the other is a pause at
the end of a clause you're gonna have to
do better than that
[Music]
okay okay i got like i got like a novel
for you okay a young lawyer passed the
bar exam and decided to get his first
tailor-made suit okay hopefully
indochino
so he went to the finest tailor in town
and got measured for a suit a week later
he went in for his first sitting he put
on the suit and looked fabulous
he felt that in this suit he will come
across as very professional okay
as he was printing himself preening
himself in front of the mirror he
reached down to put his hands in the
pockets and to a surprise he noticed
that there were no pockets he mentioned
this to the tailor who asked him didn't
you tell me you were a lawyer
the young man answered yes i did
to this the tailor said whoever heard of
a lawyer with his hands in his own
pockets
oh man come on now it's cause you
charged too much i charge a very
reasonable rate yeah in your opinion
okay devin yes sir if your mother-in-law
and a lawyer were drowning and you had
to choose
would you go to lunch or a movie
well as we've covered many times on this
channel if they're drowning on their own
accord you have no obligation to save
them i mean you should
at least save the lawyer
because lawyers contribute to society
you want to go for a swim
will you help me
no i have no legal obligation devon
[Music]
a man needing some legal help walks into
a law firm okay
he asks an attorney
if i give you 300 to help answer two
legal questions i have will you help me
the attorney replies sure what's the
other question
nice
nice actually that's just that's reading
the textual evidence that's that's
perfectly acceptable
says the lawyer absolutely get out of
here
[Music]
oh thomas it's so good to see you hello
you're my friend hi maybe oh who gave
you a love mike uh i don't know i stole
it from matt actually
he might be hurt we need to have some
words don't sue me get this a drunk man
walks into a bar looking for a fight so
he stands up in front of the bar and
yells out all lawyers
oh that's mean the bar falls silent for
a few seconds before a man finally gets
up from his table taps the drunk man on
the shoulder says take that back
drunk man responds why are you a lawyer
which the man replies no
look not all lawyers are that's that's
just not fair i mean you know
professional courtesy sharks and and all
that you're gonna need a bigger
[Music]
did you boat about the new sushi bar
that caters exclusively to lawyers i
haven't heard about this sushi bar it's
called sosumi
that seems on the cusp we'll see that
we'll see if that makes it or not i'm
not sure
a lawyer dies in his sleep and arrives
at the gates of heaven okay he asked
saint peter yes why am i here i was
healthy and so young st peter replies
young you were 103 years old
lawyer says what no i was 36. st peter
looked at his ledger and said i see the
problem we are going by hours build
so that's actually a huge issue if you
build more hours than you actually work
you can be disbarred for that maybe st
peter has the trap door too yeah i think
there's there's a there's a lawyer trap
door there that's one of the few lawyers
who doesn't deserve to get into heaven
i'll cop to that i'll cop to that
what is the most common outfit for
lawyers to wear i assume it's a suit a
lawsuit
[Music]
hi devon patch from tierzoo how's it
going mr eagle
we just did a collaboration you'll be my
friend yeah sure we'll see about that i
think someone gave you some mean lawyer
jokes yeah we even got some ones with
animal themes so it's bad
what did the lawyer use when he went
fishing what did the lawyer use
debate
nah i like that one that's a good one
that is that is a genuine lawyer skill
and
it kind of puts lawyers in a nice light
thank you patch i needed that one
anytime
[Music]
what do you call a snake that works for
the government
i don't like where this one is going
what do you call a snake that works for
the government a civil serpent
i'm okay with a good pun that i'm okay
with that i'm just gonna spike the
camera
[Music]
what's the difference between the law
and an ice cube
what is the difference between a law and
an ice cube
one is justice and the other is just ice
i feel like this one's better written
out than
well we'll put that on the screen
justice and just
ice what do you get if you send the
godfather to law school
what do you get
an offer you can't understand
i mean for that
uh you need lawyers that can write very
clearly and succinctly and uh yeah i
think don corleone would be a really
terrible lawyer it would be a tough one
tom hagan though really good lawyer
[Music]
joe scott gevin you're gonna be mean
just like everybody else aren't you yes
i brought my specs to roast you
appropriately arguing with a lawyer
is like wrestling a pig in mud
sooner or later you realize they like it
we do we really really do that's not
that's not even a joke
during a party a doctor's telling a
lawyer that he's sick of his friends
asking him for medical advice the lawyer
says just do what i do and leave a bill
in their mailbox
the doctor decides he'll give it a try
and thanks his lawyer friend and then
when he gets home he has a bill in his
mailbox from his lawyer
i wish i could get away with that i give
out so much good advice to all of my
friends whether they want it or not well
no nobody likes a lawyer until you need
one exactly you know and then they're
your best friend hopefully they like the
lawyers before that
if a lawyer gets a hip replacement
surgery did they call that procedure a
rebuttal
a re-but yeah right yeah you're
replacing your butt yeah i like it
that's a good that's a good one all
right that's a good pun well i just got
roasted so hard i'm going to have to
change my shirt and probably my shorts
but luckily i am wearing the insanely
comfortable and breathable mac weldon
from head to toe you might have heard
about mac weldon's incredible boxer
briefs including their ridiculously
comfortable stealth box of reefs which i
am wearing right now which i am not
going to show you but if you are an
adult you deserve to have some actually
comfortable summer leisure wear like mac
weldon because when i'm not in court i'm
usually wearing something like this a
super comfortable breathable polo like
this one from mac weldon or their jogger
radius pants which it's just frankly way
too hot to be wearing those right now
especially when your supposed friends
are roasting the crap out of you so when
i order them i order them in multiple
sizes i keep the ones that fit perfectly
and send back the ones that don't so if
you legal eagles out there would like to
try mack weldon for yourself go to
macweldon.com legaleagle and use the
promo code legal eagle to get 20 off
your first order you'll also join mac
weldon's blue program where you get
access to all of their stuff really
early and way before everybody else does
and you get free shipping so you can go
to macweldon.com or just click on the
link that is on screen right now to get
20 off of your first order from mack
weldon you will not be disappointed so
again if you would like to get 20 off of
your first order of mac well then just
click on the link in the description go
to macweldon.com legaleagle and be sure
to use promo code legally check out to
get 20 off or click on this link that is
on screen right now plus clicking on
this on-screen link really helps out
this channel and while you're at it
click on this playlist over here with
all of my other lawyer jokes and legal
memes so click on this playlist or i'll
see you in court